...
-Jacqueline Laffont,
excepté le totem du barreau
Henri Leclerc,
rares sont les avocats
qui fassent l'unanimité
auprès de leurs pairs.
Or à l'évocation
de votre nom, c'est toujours
un concert de louanges.
Pourquoi ?
-Je n'en sais rien.
Je pense
que je fais l'objet aussi
peut-être
d'une certaine bienveillance,
peut-être parce que j'ai traversé
des moments difficiles.
-J'ai une piste.
Mettons de côté vos qualités
professionnelles éprouvées
et reconnues,
votre légendaire discrétion
dans un milieu à fort ego
n'y serait-elle pas
pour quelque chose ?
-Peut-être.
Je pense que,
lorsque l'on s'expose,
on s'expose
aux critiques également.
Et donc je ne m'expose pas
si souvent que cela.
Je porte peut-être moins
le flanc à la critique
ou aux jalousies.
Beaucoup de choses se passent
dans nos métiers,
dans tous les métiers
probablement,
d'envie.
Voilà.
-Alors,
Emmanuelle Kneusé,
votre consoeur...
-Et amie.
-Dit que la discrétion fait partie
de vos gènes
et de cette génération.
-Oui, c'est vrai qu'on est
peut-être une génération
plus discrète.
Moi, en ce qui
me concerne, j'ai toujours eu
une façon de régler
cette question.
C'est : est-ce que ça sert
mon client ou pas ?
Et comme je pense qu'en définitive,
notre rôle, notre mission,
elle s'exerce
dans les tribunaux, devant
les tribunaux,
devant les juges...
-Et en aucun cas
dans une arène médiatique.
Défendre un ancien président
de la République, est-ce
le même exercice qu'un quidam ?
-Ca mobilise toujours les mêmes
ressorts, c'est-à-dire que moi,
je pense que ce métier,
on doit le faire
avec une forte capacité
d'indignation, de combat.
Chaque défense de chaque homme,
de chaque femme,
c'est à chaque fois un combat
pour plus de justice.
Il y a évidemment
des différences
et puis il y a pour l'essentiel
beaucoup de points communs.
-Vous avez été
l'avocate de Nicolas Sarkozy
entre autres.
-Je le suis toujours.
-Vous êtes
aux yeux du public
l'avocate des puissants,
Charles Pasqua,
Serge Dassault,
Ali Bongo, Laurent Gbagbo,
Jean-Marie Messier,
Nicolas Sarkozy, on l'a cité,
Alexandre Benalla,
Nicolas Hulot,
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor
ou encore Damien Abad.
D'ailleurs,
comment défend-on à l'ère
de MeToo et des gilets jaunes ?
-On doit les défendre
plus que jamais.
Plus que jamais.
J'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui
qu'on est dans une ère
où, effectivement,
on veut se passer
de la médiation de la justice,
de la médiation de la règle,
de la médiation de la loi, de la
médiation de cet espace sacralisé,
qui fait qu'on a une décision
qui est le fruit de règles,
d'une procédure.
Une décision
de justice n'existe pas
si elle n'est pas recueillie
selon des règles
qui sont arrêtées par la loi
et la justice directe,
immédiate, pour moi,
n'est pas une justice.
Donc,
plus que jamais,
il faut se battre,
parce qu'il y a des dérives
qui, à mon avis,
sont inquiétantes.
Je pense que beaucoup
de nos grands principes
sont en train de voler en éclats.
-Diriez-vous que l'époque
entre en dissonance
avec les droits de la défense ?
Plus que jamais ?
-Oui.
C'est quand même la grande époque
de... de l'accusation.
Je trouve que c'est quand même
la mode de l'accusation.
-L'interpellation publique.
-La mode
de la dénonciation sauvage,
publique, sans ces règles
qui font la justice, sans
lesquelles la justice n'existe pas.
La justice
est évidemment imparfaite,
elle doit progresser toujours,
elle doit être dénoncée
lorsqu'elle a des failles,
elle doit être améliorée,
elle doit en permanence
être questionnée.
Enfin, je ne la prends pas
pour une institution
qui serait parfaite et idéale,
loin de là.
Je me bats tous les jours pour que
cette justice soit meilleure.
A chacune de mes affaires, je pense
que j'agis pour cela.
Mais la justice
reste la justice,
elle ne peut être remplacée
par rien d'autre.
Et il n'y a pas,
encore une fois,
de possibilité
de s'en affranchir.
Et c'est ça que je trouve
dangereux,
au nom de combats,
qui sont évidemment
nobles, légitimes,
beaux, nécessaires,
et tous les qualificatifs
possibles,
on vient mobiliser des ressorts
qui parfois m'inquiètent,
de volonté
de mort sociale.
La réalité, c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
point de salut
pour les personnes
qui ont été un jour
accusées dans leur vie
d'affaires, jugées ou pas.
C'est quand même important
de le rappeler.
Ces personnes n'ont plus
le droit de vivre,
n'ont plus le droit d'aller
dans un salon littéraire.
Elles n'ont plus le droit
d'être vues à un spectacle.
Donc je trouve
qu'il y a une dérive
d'une justice populiste.
-Vous évoquez,
j'imagine, PPDA et Nicolas Hulot.
On va en parler,
mais j'aimerais vous faire réagir
à cette citation :
"Le procès est d'abord
une cérémonie de paroles.
"Il met des mots
à la place de la violence,
"une peine à la place
de la vengeance, et de l'argent
"à la place de la souffrance.
C'est le sens profond de la justice
"que de substituer à l'événement
du crime un autre événement,
"celui du procès."
Ecrivent
dans "Victimes, et après ?"
Arthur Dénouveaux
et Antoine Garapon.
Comment reconnaître
les victimes
dans leur souffrance
quand les faits sont prescrits
ou les preuves insuffisantes ?
-C'est formidable que vous citiez
Arthur Dénouveaux
et Antoine Garapon, qui est
un ancien magistrat, philosophe
aussi, qui a beaucoup écrit.
Je trouve que cette citation
est très juste.
En fait, je pense qu'il y a
un leurre à vouloir
entretenir...
il
y a un temps pour tout,
il y a le temps de la justice
et il y a la loi qui,
au bout d'un certain temps,
devenu très long,
c'était probablement
nécessaire, on a rallongé
les délais de prescription,
qui vient vous dire : vous n'avez
plus le droit de juger
un homme.
Donc on vous demande
de condamner
socialement un homme
que la loi interdit de juger.
Et si vous voulez, un homme
que la loi interdit de juger,
c'est un homme
qui ne sera jamais condamné.
Un homme qui ne sera jamais
condamné est un homme
qui ne peut pas être présenté
comme un coupable.
Un homme qui n'a pas été déclaré
coupable est un innocent.
Nous avons, nous,
un rôle, une responsabilité.
Tout le monde porte
une responsabilité
sur le fait d'entretenir
certaines plaignantes,
victimes peut-être, parmi elles,
dans les plaignantes,
il y a beaucoup de victimes,
c'est une évidence,
mais dans le leurre que,
finalement, il faut la vengeance.
C'est plus une question de justice,
c'est une question de vengeance.
Eh bien non,
je pense que le deuil,
ce mot que je n'aime pas trop
et assez galvaudé,
mais doit exister
en dehors de cela.
-Comment se reconstruire
quand les faits ne sont pas
caractérisés,
quand ils sont prescrits ?
-Ce que je pense profondément,
c'est qu'on doit inciter
les femmes, quelles
qu'elles soient, ou les hommes
qui sont victimes à déposer plainte
le plus rapidement possible.
C'est quand même le meilleur moyen
que la justice fonctionne
et les délais sont longs.
On ne leur demande pas
de faire ça
dans les 24 heures
ni dans les 6 mois
ni même dans les 5 ans.
Donc,
voilà, il faut que les femmes
se dirigent
le plus nombreuses possible
vers les portes
des commissariats,
vers la justice,
qu'elles conservent les preuves,
les éléments, les textos envoyés
à leurs amis,
pour faire en sorte
que ces faits soient jugés.
Le jour où ils ne peuvent plus
être jugés, c'est la loi.
Ces mêmes personnes sont
probablement les mêmes
qui se sont battues
contre les tribunaux d'exception.
Est-ce qu'on veut dans ce cas
une justice d'exception ?
Non, il y a des lois.
On peut
les considérer parfois imparfaites,
on a des moyens qui sont ceux
de l'arsenal législatif
pour éventuellement
les faire bouger,
la politique, les députés,
il y a des institutions,
mais si vous voulez, pour moi,
on arrive quand même
à une justice très populiste,
c'est-à-dire qu'on vient
finalement faire
des dénonciations sauvages,
défier les institutions.
Moi, je les combats tous les jours,
je les trouve insuffisantes,
mais...
Et finalement s'affranchir
de la loi et de la règle
et je trouve ça dangereux.
-Que répondriez-vous
à Adèle Haenel qui désespère
de la justice de son pays ?
Un viol sur dix aboutit
à une condamnation.
Qu'en est-il des 9 autres ?
Qu'en est-il de ces vies ?
Si la justice veut être
à l'image de la société,
elle doit absolument
se remettre en question.
-La justice doit
Elle s'est déjà pas mal remise
en question sur ces sujets-là.
Et moi, ce que je lui réponds,
c'est que, lorsque j'accompagne
des femmes, car j'en accompagne
aussi dans ces parcours,
qui sont des parcours
douloureux et difficiles,
je pense qu'on a un rôle.
Vous, les journalistes, avez
un rôle, nous, avocats, aussi,
c'est celui de leur expliquer
qu'il y a des règles
et que, s'il y a
une plainte à déposer,
car elles souhaitent la déposer,
car elles estiment avoir été
victimes de faits, nous sommes là
pour les accompagner,
mais il faut leur expliquer
qu'au bout de cela,
il y aura une décision
de justice.
Et cette décision sera peut-être
difficile à accepter ou pas,
mais elle sera celle
qui sera rendue
selon des lois
qui nous protègent tous,
qui nous protégeront
tous demain,
qui protégeront ces femmes,
leurs enfants, leurs frères, etc.
Donc je pense qu'il faut
accepter cette justice
avec ces imperfections-là, car
il n'y a pas mieux que la justice.
-J'aimerais essayer
de voir avec vous
comment sortir
de cette quadrature de cercle
avec d'un côté des victimes
qui se sentent méprisées,
de l'autre des accusés condamnés
sans autre forme
de procès.
Comment on en sort ?
-Je pense qu'on a tous à agir.
Je pense qu'il y a...
Qu'il y a quelque chose à faire
accepter et comprendre
aux personnes qui sont
victimes, qui sont plaignantes.
Ou plaignants.
Je pense aussi
que la presse
a un rôle à jouer.
Aujourd'hui,
je vois la place énorme
qui a été donnée
dans les quotidiens d'information
sur ces sujets,
les premières pour sortir
et promouvoir des livres,
bon, et la place qui est donnée
à côté de cela
à ceux qui se défendent,
elle est à la fois dérisoire
et lorsqu'ils osent
prendre la parole une fois,
ils en entendent parler
pendant 2 ans,
au point qu'on leur dit,
arrêtez de prendre la parole.
Donc il y a
toute une éducation à refaire,
qui est en train de voler
en éclats sur le fait
que ce n'est pas
parce qu'on vient rappeler
la règle, la loi, les principes
que l'on porte atteinte
à des combats nobles et légitimes.
Les deux peuvent coexister.
Il faut que ça se rencontre,
que les journalistes laissent
plus de place à ça,
qu'ils écrivent
dans leurs articles qu'un homme
dont les faits ne peuvent pas
être jugés car la loi l'interdit,
on ne pourra jamais dire
qu'il est coupable.
Jamais.
C'est comme ça.
Il faut
que les victimes
qui veulent s'exprimer
aient conscience de cela,
et vous savez, je
me dis de temps en temps,
on entend beaucoup de femmes
venir dire
qu'elles ont mis 30 ans
à réaliser,
que ce qui s'était passé
ce soir-là, c'était peut-être pas
une relation normale, etc.
-Et qui invoquent
l'amnésie traumatique.
-Oui.
Alors,
l'amnésie traumatique...
Mais moi, ce que...
Qui est
un peu remise en question.
Je pense que l'emprise existe,
que l'amnésie traumatique
existe,
mais ce sont des concepts
qui ont été vraiment galvaudés,
et que, si vous voulez, on peut
aussi interroger ces femmes,
vous êtes une femme, je suis
une femme, on peut toutes avoir
des mauvais souvenirs peut-être,
mais, à un moment donné,
si elles-mêmes ont mis 30 ans
à se dire que finalement
la façon dont les choses
s'étaient passé ce jour-là,
peut-être qu'on peut aussi se dire
que la personne qui a partagé
cette relation-là n'a pas eu
cette conscience-là non plus.
Quand on parle
de ces affaires de viol-là,
il y a beaucoup d'autres affaires
dont on parle très peu,
que j'accompagne de temps
en temps, elles occupent
beaucoup moins
les unes des journaux,
mais ces affaires-là,
dont on parle,
parce que c'est de celles-ci
je pense qu'on peut aussi
interroger cela.
On est dans une vision manichéenne,
le bien et le mal,
sur des sujets qui sont
infiniment complexes,
des faits qui sont revisités
des années plus tard,
à l'aune d'une évolution
que je trouve
par ailleurs complètement
souhaitable et légitime,
mais, voilà, rien n'est
aussi simple que ça
et je pense que cette nuance-là,
ce serait bien que...
oui, qu'elle ressurgisse
chez les uns et chez les autres.
-La cour d'appel de Versailles
a exhumé récemment
une jurisprudence de la Cour
de cassation datant de 2005
indiquant que,
si des faits prescrits
s'inscrivent en liens précis
avec d'autres faits non prescrits,
la justice peut mener son cours
sans se soucier des dates.
C'est la sérialité des faits.
Si ces liens sont établis,
cela changera-t-il la donne
pour bon nombre
d'affaires en cours ?
-Oui, ça changera
sûrement la donne
pour un certain nombre
d'affaires en cours.
Vous faites référence
à un arrêt
que je n'ai jamais lu,
puisqu'il est dans un dossier
qui concerne un de mes clients,
mais auquel je n'ai pas accès.
Client qui a fait l'objet
d'un classement sans suite.
Pour l'instant,
nous en sommes là.
Sur des faits non prescrits.
-PPDA.
-Voilà.
Je ne vais pas parler
de son cas en particulier,
mais pour en revenir
à cet arrêt-là, je ne l'ai pas lu.
J'aimerais bien le lire en entier
pour pouvoir le commenter.
Là, ce sont quelques extraits
qui ont été publiés dans la presse
et que j'ai lus.
Donc je ne sais
pas comment c'est écrit
et comment c'est présenté
par la chambre de l'instruction.
Mais le jour où, si ce jour arrive,
je ne sais pas s'il arrivera,
mais où cette décision
de justice
me serait éventuellement opposable,
ce qui n'est pas évident,
à ce moment-là, je la lirais
et éventuellement je pourrais
la commenter et éventuellement
exercer un recours
si je pense que, juridiquement,
il y a un recours.
-J'aimerais vous faire réagir
à cette réflexion
d'une magistrate du siège,
en région parisienne,
interrogée en décembre 2021,
par le journal Libération,
qui affirmait, je cite, que :
"La preuve ne repose pas
"nécessairement
sur des éléments matériels,
"on peut prononcer
des culpabilités
"à partir
de témoignages concordants."
Est-ce exact ?
La concordance peut peser ?
-Oui.
Oui.
-Je pensais
que seule la preuve de la
contrainte était exigée par la loi,
qu'il ne suffisait pas de dire
"je n'étais pas consentante",
encore fallait-il le démontrer.
-Oui, mais pour le démontrer,
vous pouvez effectivement,
enfin, les juridictions,
les tribunaux,
les juridictions de jugement
peuvent retenir
un certain nombre d'éléments
et des témoignages
qui seraient concordants,
normalement des témoignages directs
des faits, ce sont des affaires
où il n'y a pas si souvent
des témoignages directs
et en général,
il n'y en a pas.
Mais si vous avez
un certain nombre d'éléments,
d'un texto que vous envoyez,
une amie à qui vous en avez parlé
en sortant,
vous êtes sortie en pleurant,
vous êtes allée voir
un médecin en sortant,
il y a effectivement...
-S'il y a un amoncellement
de preuves concordantes.
-Un amoncellement
d'éléments concordants,
qui viennent conforter
les déclarations
d'une personne, s'il y a
un certificat médical
où on constate
des lésions, etc., oui,
à ce moment-là, on peut arriver
à une condamnation,
qui est justifiée ou pas.
C'est
une question d'analyse de dossier
et de cas par cas.
-A propos de consentement,
la sociologue Irène Théry propose
d'introduire dans le Code pénal
la notion de crédit de véracité
permettant à celles et ceux
dénonçant des violences sexuelles
de ne plus être soupçonnés de
mentir jusqu'à preuve du contraire.
Est-ce une piste à creuser ?
-Je pense qu'encore une fois,
là, on arrive à l'inversion totale
de nos principes fondamentaux,
de ce qui fait le socle
de notre procédure pénale.
Au départ, quand une femme va
déposer plainte pour un viol,
la présomption de véracité,
dans les faits, elle existe,
mais de proposer, comme le fait
Irène Théry, d'en faire un principe
qui vient totalement bouleverser
la règle de notre droit,
qui est
que c'est à l'accusation
qu'incombe
la charge de la preuve,
je suis
contre les justices d'exception
quelles qu'elles soient, contre
ce qui ferait de ces faits-là,
je dirais, des faits
qui feraient l'objet
d'un régime dérogatoire,
et je pense que,
encore une fois,
ces affaires doivent être
jugées comme les autres,
avec la même exigence
de recherche de vérité,
la même exigence de respect
de la parole donnée,
mais la même exigence
de rechercher des indices
et des preuves d'une culpabilité.
-Jacqueline Laffont,
depuis la déflagration
causée par l'affaire Duhamel
et le mouvement MeTooInceste,
des femmes et des hommes politiques
se disent favorables
à l'imprescriptibilité des crimes
sexuels sur mineurs.
Et vous ?
-Je pense que la prescription
des affaires criminelles
sexuelles sur mineurs
a été considérablement rallongée,
puisque, maintenant,
on a le droit de déposer plainte,
on peut déposer plainte
jusqu'à ses 48 ans,
donc 30 ans après sa majorité
et parfois plus que cela, puisque
des faits peuvent avoir eu lieu
quelques années
auparavant encore.
Je pense qu'une justice
qui intervient si tardivement
est une justice
qui n'en est plus une.
Ces règles de prescription,
elles ont été rallongées.
Pour le coup, l'amnésie traumatique
chez les enfants,
je pense que ça a probablement plus
de sens, ça peut avoir un sens
et puis, on est dans un univers
familial, c'est plus compliqué,
les enfants doivent être protégés
plus que d'autres, etc.
Mais on ne peut pas
aller au-delà.
C'est totalement déraisonnable.
La prescription, ça n'est pas fait
pour protéger les coupables,
c'est fait pour protéger
une justice qui ait un sens.
C'est un rempart
contre l'arbitraire.
contre des procès sans preuves.
Bien sûr.
Non, je suis
fondamentalement contre.
Et puis, quand même, je repense
à cette pauvre Elisabeth Badinter,
qui s'est fait conspuer...
-Ecoutons-la.
-Très bien.
*-Où on est maintenant ?
Où sommes-nous ?
*Pour mépriser à ce point
la justice ?
*Je suis parfaitement
*en accord avec le ministre de la
Justice et ses déclarations d'hier,
*on peut pas à ce point mépriser
les principes démocratiques.
*-Eric Dupond-Moretti a dit :
*il est temps de siffler
la fin de la récréation.
*C'est extraordinairement dangereux
ce qui est en train de se passer,
*certains se font dévorer
par un monstre qu'ils ont créé.
*Les réseaux sociaux ne peuvent pas
être l'unique réceptacle
*sans filtre de cette parole.
La justice doit intervenir.
*Mme Rousseau n'est pas procureur
de la nation.
C'est ce qu'il dit.
*-Ce que reprochent,
et je peux le comprendre,
*les féministes de MeToo
à la justice,
*et raisons pour lesquelles
elles leur tournent le dos,
*c'est la question
de la prescription.
*Quand c'est prescrit,
*il n'y a pas
d'enquête policière.
*Non, non, non.
C'est la fin, je dirais,
*de la présomption d'innocence
et d'un travail sérieux.
*On n'est pas non plus...
On peut s'interroger,
*pourquoi on ne porterait pas
plainte avant la prescription ?
*-Parce que, parfois,
les femmes se taisent.
*-Pardon ?
*-Parfois, les femmes se taisent.
*-Il faut aussi prendre
ses responsabilités.
*Je comprends très bien que,
pendant un certain temps,
*même des années,
ça soit impossible à évoquer,
*mais quand même, 10 ans...
-Bien plus que 10 ans.
-La philosophe Elisabeth Badinter
s'est fait incendier
sur les réseaux
après ses propos
sur MeTooPolitique.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Certaines avocates considèrent
qu'ils sont très violents.
-Ecoutez, moi, d'abord,
c'est une femme
envers laquelle j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration,
j'oublie pas ses combats.
C'est une féministe avant tout.
Et je trouve que,
vraiment, les réactions
auxquelles cet entretien a...
-A suscité.
-Voilà.
Sont absolument
scandaleuses.
Racistes.
Violentes.
Immondes.
Et c'est ce que je vous disais,
derrière ces combats nobles,
je trouve qu'il y a des ressorts
très inquiétants quand même.
Et je pense
qu'il n'est pas possible
de ne pas accepter la discussion.
Qu'elle se soit faite
de cette manière-là,
je dirais, insultée
à la suite de cette réaction,
je pense que
c'est proprement inadmissible,
mais j'aimerais entendre
les personnes
le dire.
Ensuite,
elle exprime un point de vue.
On a encore le droit
d'exprimer son point de vue.
Et ensuite, moi, je suis, je ne
dirais peut-être pas les choses...
chacun dit les choses
à sa manière,
mais je suis absolument
d'accord avec elle
sur le fait que
ce que l'on veut en fait
anéantir,
c'est dans ces affaires-là
la présomption d'innocence.
Non, elle doit exister
et c'est ça, le combat,
qui est un combat difficile.
Et je partage totalement
ce qu'elle a dit.
-Pensez-vous que la prescription
peut aider la parole à émerger,
que c'est une incitation ?
-Ecoutez, je pense que ça peut
être une incitation.
Cette prescription,
elle est, non pas de 10 ans,
mais de 20 ans et de 30 ans
pour les mineurs,
donc elle est déjà
extrêmement longue.
Ensuite, il y a l'idée
de la justice.
Cela a-t-il un sens,
ces procès si longtemps après
dans des affaires où il est déjà
difficile d'avoir les preuves
juste après les faits ?
Ca ne peut donner lieu
qu'à des frustrations,
qu'à une parodie de justice.
Enfin, ça n'a pas de sens.
Et puis, par ailleurs, oui,
ça doit inciter les femmes
à déposer plainte.
Dans des affaires
où, par exemple,
il y a 30, 40, 90 personnes qui
viennent se plaindre de faits,
comment vous expliquez
qu'il y en ait 90
qui n'aient pas eu l'idée,
pas une, de déposer plainte
dans le délai de la prescription ?
On doit aussi s'interroger.
Il faut dire les choses.
-Comment expliquez-vous
que 90 femmes n'aient pas osé
porter plainte avant les délais
de prescription ?
-Certaines d'entre elles
disent elles-mêmes
qu'à l'époque,
elles n'ont pas eu
conscience de ça.
Donc on revisite les choses.
Moi, je suis prête à parler
de toutes les affaires
que vous voulez, qui ont lieu
là aujourd'hui,
celles-ci, on en entend
beaucoup moins parler.
Je suis en train d'accompagner
une jeune femme
qui a fait l'objet d'un viol,
je suis aux côtés de plein
de femmes dans ce cas,
c'est normal, je les accompagne
dans ces faits-là, j'en accompagne
certaines même qui sont venues me
voir pour des affaires prescrites,
mais je suis toujours claire,
je suis toujours en cohérence
avec moi-même.
Quel que soit le côté
de la barre, j'ai
toujours le même discours.
-Quand Elise Lucet insiste
sur le fait qu'il n'existe pas
de prescription journalistique,
qu'est-ce que
cela vous inspire ?
-Franchement...
Elise Lucet, les émissions
qu'elle a consacrées
à certaines
de ces affaires médiatiques,
dont certaines sont
à mon cabinet,
je pense que ce sont...
des lynchages,
des lynchages en règle.
Dans lesquels il n'y a aucune place
pour une autre parole.
Au point que, moi, je renonce
totalement à la prendre.
Il n'y a pas de place pour ça.
Vous êtes enfermé
dans quelque chose de compliqué.
Si vous portez une autre parole,
si vous venez simplement rappeler
des choses évidentes,
basiques, telles que les principes,
vous êtes disqualifié,
vous êtes accusé d'être contre
ce combat-là.
-Malgré tout,
les journalistes ont
un rôle à jouer.
Depuis l'affaire
Dreyfus, on sait que les enquêtes
peuvent amener à des ouvertures
de poursuites, de procédures.
-Depuis l'affaire Dreyfus,
vous savez, de temps en temps,
je me dis, c'est là
que les choses changent.
Depuis Outreau,
j'essaie de chercher une affaire
où des journalistes ont recherché
une innocence.
Je n'en ai pas trouvé.
Il y a des principes
qui doivent être sacrés.
Or ils ne le sont plus
aujourd'hui.
On s'affranchit
de ces principes
au nom de la noblesse
d'un combat.
Et derrière la noblesse
de ce combat,
on voit ressurgir des choses
que je trouve encore une fois
pas forcément très belles
et très respectables toujours.
C'est, encore une fois,
cette volonté de mort sociale.
-"A chaque fois que je me lève
pour défendre quelqu'un,
"je me dis que je suis à ma place.
Il faut y croire quand on entre
"dans l'arène."
C'est ce que
vous disiez sur France Inter.
Vous arrive-t-il
d'en douter ?
-Moi, vous savez,
je doute beaucoup.
Je doute beaucoup.
Je doute
avant chaque plaidoirie,
après chacune,
je pense que le doute,
c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui doit vous accompagner.
C'est pas facile d'être
habité par le doute
en permanence, sur soi,
sur ses capacités,
est-ce qu'on fait bien, mal, etc.
Moi, le doute m'accompagne
sur tout, dans tout,
tout le temps,
donc évidemment
dans mon métier.
En revanche,
je ne doute jamais
qu'un homme ou une femme
doit toujours être défendu.
Je n'ai jamais autant envie
de défendre les gens
que lorsqu'ils sont
accablés, lynchés.
Parfois, on me dit,
arrête de défendre
Untel, Untel, etc.
Mais en fait,
je pense que, oui, voilà,
quand on défend, on est un peu seul
contre tous.
C'est dur par moments.
C'est dur, mais le jour où
je n'aurai plus envie de faire ça,
il faudra
que j'arrête d'être avocat.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...